so yamamoto battled for the fifth spot
in the rotation during summer camp sent
to the alternate site just before
opening day
and uh again the third hawaiian-born
player to appear for the marlins and
they are looking for big things out of
him tonight going forward
there's a strikeout for yamamoto his
first
of the ball game balling two strikes on
iglesias and he chases that one
back-to-back strikeouts for yamamoto
that's a good look at it right little
tight uh
spin right there that's not the sweeping
slider here's the pitch
and breaking ball swung on a miss put
him away gave up a lead off double to
alberto
he stranded at second base as jordan
struck out
the next three batters good work
jordan yamamoto
wade leblanc ready to go for the o's
against a former oriole in jonathan vr
and a home run to lead things off in the
bottom of the first inning welcome back
to charm city one-nothing marlins
well we've said throughout the first
three games of this series we've seen an
aggressive jonathan vr how about no
waiting around in game four
love to see it
fastball up 87 miles an hour that's
leblanc uh
he's probably as fast as you're going to
see tonight a beautiful swing little
two-seam action
just split the play look at the
extension from the right side and no
doubt this ball hit a ton
two balls no strikes to renato nunez
that's tagged nobody's gonna catch that
one
way back and gone
renato nunez answers the vr home run
with his third of the season
that's what i'm talking about nunes
three home runs now this season head off
the bat at 102 traveled
401 feet that ball was absolutely smoked
and now this one out to right center
field long run monte harrison oh and he
gets there makes the catch terrific
speed cisco moves up 90 feet but it
could have been a lot more
if not for the great athleticism of mate
harrison now this is the second
fantastic catch we've seen from monte
here at camden yards full extension
very graceful just in front of the
warning track got a good read good break
finishes it off he saves the marlins a
run
ball is trying to get that one run back
now second and third and just one out
that'll bring magneris sierra to the
plate left-hand hitter
see if they can get one here a one-one
from sierra that might be it or at least
deep enough it's going to stay up for
santander brinson coming home and he
will score sierra with a sacrifice fly
and the marlins are back in front
roberto running santander rips it deep
to center harrison fading back won't get
this one crashes against the wall
around third alberto and he will score
santander into third and now we need to
check on harrison because he hit that
wall hard out in center field that he
went in with a full head of steam yeah
he did he sold out to the catch and
unable to come up with the ball i'm not
sure if the ball would have entered his
glove as hard as he hit the wall if he
would have even held onto it
a smile on his face thankfully and he's
heading back out to his position in
center field so fortunately looks like
he's going to stay in the ball game
dwight smith
that might do it
well hit center field
harrison under it
santander
will come home to give the orioles a 3-2
lead
rbi on dwight smith's sac fly birds go
on top
pilar
bounces it to short oh look at that play
iglesias gets him with a one-hopper to
davis
beautiful play covered a lot of ground
jose iglesias arguably one of top five
shortstops in all of baseball in his
career a little spin throw it was
accurate enough a nice stretch by chris
davis well now a guy that should
certainly like at the plate in a spot
like this with two in scoring position
and two outs
brian anderson in the right center field
a base hit cervelli scores easily
rounding third aguilar throw is cut off
and the marlins back in front the seesaw
continues four to three
chances go with a double the left is
first at back
fly ball
hit well
way back and ride it's out of here
chance cisco having himself a knife
after a double the left in the second he
leaves the building and we're tied at
four may take ten to win this one
tonight ben
here is vr homered in the first inning
poke through the right side of base hit
that will score forsyth on to third goes
sierra the throw is late and it gets
away
and he will come home and score down
goes trey hillman who looks to be all
right so is the marlins offense they put
six on the board
that ball's hit well
smith rips into it way back and gone
the white smith who had driven in a run
with a sacrifice fly leaves the building
and the leads cut to one
well hop on the first one schmidty
i thought the white's been two home runs
this season
way to go merriman lottery there's a
deep drive way back
and nunez has his second home of the
game
and the orioles have tied it up with a
couple of long balls back to back dwight
smith and renato nunez
well the boom sticks are out tonight for
the orioles
put it in play you got a chance to
succeed
hit it high and deep to left field that
might work too drifting back is smith on
the track will make the catch and that
is going to score john bertie and up to
second goes cervelli as sac fly for
jesus aguilar and the marlins take a
lead in the seventh
oh now brian anderson with a drive out
to center field austin hayes off his
glove that will score cervelli around
third on his way to third is anderson
and the marlins lead at eight to six
now iglesias
and a ground ball that's birdie the flip
to logan forsyth it's a marlins win
don mattingly the marlins have won five
straight games to take their record to
six and one and don mattingly along the
way here tonight picks up his 282nd win
as a marlins manager and is now the
all-time leader in managerial wins for
the marlins